to know how to protect your information
discover the methods of obtaining it a
simple Google image search won't
surprise anyone and if the scammer is
impersonating someone else you probably
won't find anything but there are other
methods for example there are
specialized sites for finding and
recognizing faces from photos such as
site searches not just for the same
photo as the one you uploaded but for
other photos with the face you are
looking for this site lets you find out
where the photo was taken so you can
always check for example matching photos
of an online acquaintance which show the
area and find out if he is telling the
truth about himself if you haven't found
any suitable photos check the metadata
information of the received file here
you can find out the time when the photo
was taken and even GPS coordinates of
the place it was taken see links to the
sites in the comments to this video
follow us to save useful information
[Music]